all right so imagine you're a fortnite
pro set to compete in a weekly
tournament series hosted by one of the
biggest streamers on the planet
you're competing for a cut of the 80 000
prize pool and hey
you actually win the damn thing but then
in a post game interview you call
everyone
dog [ __ ] and trash the rest of the
competitive scene
so now you're banned from ever competing
in that series
and the org you're signed to has
threatened to drop you
that's exactly what happened to fortnite
pro's x-row last week
alright guys so the score is streaming
over on twitch.tv
slash the score esports so if you
haven't already go ahead and follow the
channel
maybe you'll catch me team killing
another colleague or taking part in our
weekly talk show clouded
which airs every wednesday at 1pm
eastern
all right now back to the story so on
may 27th
ninja announced ninja battles featuring
fortnite a six week series with
each week having an 80 000 prize pool up
for grabs
with people like booga cipher nate hill
and scope signed up with even more names
yet to be announced
it's a pretty flashy lineup and the
eventual winner of week one which kicked
off a day later on may 28th
was a trio of tsm's zex row mackwood and
their third
calc
soon after finding out they won zex row
with that same energy and trash talk you
just saw
went into a post-game interview with the
casters and it's
here where everything went wrong last
fncs didn't go too well but i just made
more than
top nine in it so everyone that didn't
place in top 10 can like
suck my dick they're [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't know how they talk [ __ ] they're
actually also a dog [ __ ] and brain dead
that's all i'm saying
after whatever that was zex row
immediately kind of
sort of but not really apologized on
twitter and
the first reply to that tweet was from
ninja who made it
very clear that this would be his last
ninja battles appearance
from there zex row posted another
apology
followed by a twitter quote i want to
directly apologize to ninja and the
tournament organizers for overshadowing
what otherwise was a great tournament
that was fun to play in with my immature
actions i am also sorry to tsm and my
fans for disappointing you guys
i should live up to the standards of a
professional and in that moment
i didn't end quote a day later tsm's ceo
reginald released a statement saying
that xexro's comments were out of line
the org would be finding him one month's
salary and that if he ever pulled
something like this again
they'd be dropping him quote xrro has
been a valuable member of our
organization for some time
and we hope to help him learn and grow
from this incident
that said we have informed him that we
have a no tolerance policy for this kind
of behavior
and that we will be forced to part ways
if something like this should ever occur
again in the future
end quote now the backlash to zex rose
comments has brought up a classic
esports debate
what role does trash talking play in
these scenes
is it good or is it bad on one hand some
people think that zexaro's comments
don't belong in esports
especially on a stream where you know
young people are watching
i mean it's ninja we're talking about
and then there's some people who think
that a bit of bm builds personalities
and creates story lines that fans can
relate to
i mean who doesn't love talking a little
[ __ ]
why am i so much [ __ ] better than you
god damn people compete at things all
the time
whether it's sports or esports you want
to talk a little trash
maybe you even want to kill a co-worker
in an office csgo match
devin sucks
it lets us know who these pro players
actually are
and let's be honest a dope pop-off is so
much more fun to watch than a bland
nice game cliche and if you're on the
receiving end of some [ __ ] talk it gives
you
all the motivation you need to crush
that [ __ ] the next time you play them
everyone is just this bland ass pro this
girl says they played well
i'm so happy for them i hope they win
nobody does that
nobody really hopes someone else wins
that guy i don't give a crap about
i like him as a person and i think he's
a good guy but i don't want him to win
never i just think that this team is
planned every sport from cs go to dota
to overwatch has its fair share of trash
talk during competition
it gets you hyped up and it gives you
something more to care about than just
who won the game streamers like dr
disrespect have built their entire
personas around trash talking
even ninja the king of family friendly
streaming
talks a ton of [ __ ]
suck a dick dude literally the fattest
one you can find i want you to
want to just literally just just hold
just shove the whole thing in your mouth
i mean even booing in esports is
controversial we did an entire
don't at me about it but then there were
cases like this one where
zex row clearly didn't read the room
even with the high of winning 25 grand
which is what the trio took home
zexros should have known what type of
post game interview he was walking into
or at the very least he should have
understood what tournament and whose
stream he was competing on
you're always taking a risk by talking
trash so if you tell thousands of people
watching to suck your dick
yeah you might get banned even his trio
partner calc
noted that it was the wrong place and
time to drop those comments
but i wonder if he said the exact same
thing after winning a tournament hosted
by faze clan
would people be pissed at all my my
trash talk
i'm very bad at trash talking yeah it's
just me getting angry and swearing at
the other person it's not like any sort
of creative like
i've never been good at that you just
like you don't trash talk you just throw
it
yeah exactly
i suppose you can't really blame devin
because to get a lot of practice at
trash talking you would have to like
win a lot all right colton
i see what you're doing there